from detecting skin cancer to sorting
cucumbers
to detecting escalators in need of
repair machine learning has granted
computer systems entirely new abilities
but how does it really work under the
hood let's walk through a basic example
and use it as an excuse to talk about
the process of getting answers from your
data
using machine learning welcome to cloud
ai adventures
my name is eufan guo on this show we'll
explore the art
science and tools of machine learning
let's pretend that we've been asked to
create a system that answers the
question of whether a drink is wine or
beer
this question answering system that we
build is called a model
and this model is created via a process
called training
machine learning the goal of training is
to create
an accurate model that answers our
questions correctly most of the time
but in order to train a model we need to
collect data
to train on this is where we will begin
our data will be collected from glasses
of wine and beer
there are many aspects of drinks that we
could collect data on
everything from the amount of foam to
the shape of the glass but for our
purposes we'll just pick two simple ones
the color as a wavelength of light and
the alcohol content as a percentage
the hope is that we can split our two
types of drinks along these two factors
alone
we'll call these our features from now
on color and alcohol the first step to
our process will be to run out to the
local grocery store
buy up a bunch of different drinks and
get some equipment to do our
measurements
a spectrometer for measuring the color
and a hydrometer to measure the alcohol
content
it appears that our grocery store has an
electronics hardware section as well
once our equipment and booze we got it
all set up it's time for our first real
step
of machine learning gathering that data
this step is very important
because the quality and quantity of data
that you gather will directly determine
how good your predictive model can be
in this case the data we collect will be
the color and alcohol content of each
drink
this will yield us a table of color
alcohol content and
whether it's beer or wine this will be
our training data
so a few hours of measurements later
we've gathered our training data
and had a few drinks perhaps and now
it's time for our next step of machine
learning
data preparation where we load our data
into a suitable place
and prepare it for use in our machine
learning training
we'll first put all our data together
then randomize the ordering
we wouldn't want the order of our data
to affect how we learn since
that's not part of determining whether a
drink is beer or wine
in other words we want to make a
determination of what a drink is
independent of what drink came before or
after in the sequence
this is also a good time to do any
pertinent visualizations of your data
helping you see if there's any relevant
relationships between different
variables
as well as show you if there are any
data imbalances for instance if we
collected
way more data points about beer than
wine the model we train will be heavily
biased toward guessing that virtually
everything it sees
is beer since it would be right most of
the time
however in the real world the model may
see beer and wine an equal amount
which would mean that it would be
guessing beer wrong half the time
we also need to split the data into two
parts the first part
used in training our model will be the
majority of our data set
the second part will be used for
evaluating our trained model's
performance
we don't want to use the same data that
the model was trained on
for evaluation since then it would just
be able to memorize the questions
just as you wouldn't want to use the
questions from your math homework on the
math exam
sometimes the data we collect needs
other forms of adjusting and
manipulation
things like deduplication normalization
error correction and others these would
all happen at the data preparation step
in our case we don't have any further
data preparation needs so
let's move on forward the next step in
our workflow
is choosing a model there are many
models that researchers and data
scientists have created over the years
some are very well suited for image data
others for sequences such as
text or music some for numerical data
and others for
text-based data in our case we have just
two features
color and alcohol percentage we can use
a small linear model
which is a fairly simple one that'll get
the job done
now we move on to what is often
considered the bulk of machine learning
the training in this step we'll use our
data
to incrementally improve our model's
ability to predict whether a given drink
is wine or beer in some ways this is
similar to someone first learning to
drive
at first they don't know how any of the
pedals knobs and switches work or when
they should be pressed
or used however after lots of practice
and correcting for their mistakes
a licensed driver emerges moreover after
a year of driving
they've become quite adept at driving
the act of driving and reacting to real
world data has adapted their driving
abilities
honing their skills we will do this on a
much smaller scale with our drinks
in particular the formula for a straight
line is y equals
mx plus b where x is the input
m is the slope of the line b is the y
y-intercept and
y is the value of the line at that
position x
the values we have available to us to
adjust or train
are just m and b where the m
is that slope and b is the y-intercept
there's no other way to
affect the position of the line since
the only other variables are x
our input and y our output in machine
learning there are many m's
since there may be many features the
collection of these values
is usually formed into a matrix that is
denoted w
for the weights matrix similarly for b
we arrange them together and that's
called
the biases the training process involves
initializing some random values for w
and b and attempting to predict the
outputs with those values
as you might imagine it does pretty
poorly at first
but we can compare our model's
predictions with the output that it
should have produced
and adjust the values in w and b such
that we will have
more accurate predictions on the next
time around
so this process then repeats each
iteration or cycle of updating the
weights and biases is called
one training step so let's look at what
that means more concretely for our data
set
when we first start the training it's
like we drew a random line through the
data
then as each step of the training
progresses the line moves step by step
closer to the ideal separation of the
wine and beer
once training is complete it's time to
see if the model is any good
using evaluation this is where that data
set that we set aside earlier
comes into play evaluation allows us to
test our model against data
that has never been used for training
this metric allows us to see how the
model might perform
against data that has not yet seen this
is meant to be representative of how the
model might perform in the real world
a good rule of thumb i use for a
training evaluation split
is somewhere on the order of 80 20 or 70
30.
much of this depends on the size of the
original source data set
if you have a lot of data perhaps you
don't need as big of a fraction
for the evaluation data set once you've
done evaluation
it's possible that you want to see if
you can further improve your training in
any way
we can do this by tuning some of our
parameters
there were a few that we implicitly
assumed when we did our training and now
is a good time to go back and test those
assumptions try other values
one example of a parameter we can tune
is how many times we run
through the training set during training
we can actually show the data multiple
times
so by doing that we will potentially
lead to higher accuracies
another parameter is learning rate this
defines how far we shift the line
during each step based on the
information from the previous
training step these values all play a
role in how accurate our model can
become
and how long the training takes for more
complex models
initial conditions can play a
significant role as well in determining
the outcome of training
differences can be seen depending on
whether a model starts off training with
values initialized to zeros
versus some distribution of values and
what that distribution is
as you can see there are many
considerations at this phase of training
and it's important that you define what
makes a model good enough
for you otherwise we might find
ourselves tweaking parameters for a very
long time
now these parameters are typically
referred to as hyper parameters
the adjustment or tuning of these hyper
parameters still remains
a bit more of an art than science and
it's an experimental process that
heavily depends on the specifics of your
data set
model and training process once you're
happy with your training and hyper
parameters
guided by the evaluation step it's
finally time to use your model to do
something useful
machine learning is using data to answer
questions so
prediction or inference is that step
where we finally get to answer some
questions
this is the point of all of this work
where the value of machine learning
is realized we can finally use our model
to predict whether a given drink is wine
or beer given its color and alcohol
percentage
the power of machine learning is that we
were able to determine this
and how to differentiate between wine
and beer using our model
rather than using human judgment and
manual rules you can extrapolate the
ideas presented today
to other problem domains as well where
the same principles apply
gathering data preparing that data
choosing a model
training it and evaluating it doing your
hyper parameter tuning and finally
prediction if you're looking for more
ways to play with training and
parameters
check out the tensorflow playground it's
a completely browser-based machine
learning sandbox where you can try
different parameters and run training
against mock data sets
and don't worry you can't break the site
of course
we'll encounter more steps and nuances
in future episodes
but this serves as a good foundational
framework to help us think through the
problem
giving us a common language to think
about each step and go
deeper in the future next time on ai
adventures we will build our first
real machine learning model using code
no more drawing lines and
going over algebra
[Music]
you